what has been your your number all at
once
since since this newfound fame
four a four so so so five people all
together you're with four women yeah
what is the uh like
the girls working on each other you're
working like what like
break down what happens it's actually
very hard like you have to be a leader
to do it you are a quarterback you have
to you feel me audible audible bend over
turn around eat harass yeah like you
gotta like know how to because you don't
the worst thing that could happen is
one girl doing something everybody's
just looking like they're just staring
yeah like it's just it's awkward like
you can't let that happen
whenever you doing like multiple girls
at the same time you can never like you
gotta make sure everyone's busy every
year like you're all right you see in
your mouth
yeah yeah okay yeah oh bob yeah oh
school yeah i gotta you feel me scissor
scissors
yeah so
but that was a while ago i was like when
i was first coming in
it just happened on accident they were
like oh they were like
is that even fun having four at once it
seems like a lot of work oh it was it
was not it was not fun it was something
that that was something that you would
make a porn for because you're actually
working yeah it feels like it feels like
you you know you're worried about four
different women's feelings all at once
and making sure everyone's having
you gotta have a lot of dick for that
like you gotta have the dick like maybe
once licking the toes like a doctor
dress or what was it one riding dick one
leg in my toes i don't know what was
that song off the chronic 2001 that was
was that corrupt
yeah
you gotta have a lot of dick for that a
lot of dick for four girls
yeah
for them to be you know even oh get
[ __ ] you gotta
you like line them up just like
um
did i line him up no i was more
directive like i might have been getting
some hair like are you
uh uh
you either [ __ ] while she giving me
head
and you know boom i might have two heads
on there and they both eat them the
twofer the two first
so maybe you have two sucking your dick
while the other ones are behind each of
them
eating them running the play you feel me
down huh it's kind of like human
centipede top of the pyramid
you're the top of the
pyramid i only did that one time no five
something like that that's a fivesome
that might be an orgy
if the past three is it is it an orgy it
was it was hard though like it's not
something i deserve i'm sure it was hard
it's not something i desired it was hard
yeah it was
i wish you were there i could have
helped out i'm good man have you ever
done that like done like the the the the
having a homie like you guys passing
hoes
i had one situation y'all not real
homies until y'all you feel me i did
have a situation and it was um
it was very awkward because i my homie
had really big balls
and i was like bro
the [ __ ] is like i i couldn't like i i i
had to tag my way out because i was like
yeah i ain't in this [ __ ] you gotta like
you can't do it like that like y'all
can't both have y'all dicks out and her
head just
trying to suck you can't do it like that
no it's like one on the end yeah you got
to be on both ends you got it right so
this is something you've done it's just
like a few times
oh we have plenty of time
so for you someone's not an actual homie
until you guys [ __ ] a [ __ ] together
is that what you're saying
no not actual homie we just a little
closer you know
just a little it's just another type of
bomb well what are the rules well what
are the rules there right because you
don't want to cross swords like that
that's why i say you got to be at
several days and then and then you
switch yeah it's rotate you can't don't
don't i don't even rotate on the same
side of her you go around this side of
where i go around the side of it yeah
you guys can't even pass each other yeah
yeah yeah you don't want to pass your
boy with both dicks out that's weird
because then you're going to see his
balls so you probably i was probably
getting head together no no no no no no
i just happened to take oh
[ __ ] i can't even see it i'm out i can't
see it i'm gone i'm ch i'm checking out
man um
that's like the old me i don't even do
that type of [ __ ] no more
this is what we've seen now you're
calmed down
yeah like now
i'm cool with like one i'd rather just
take care of the fam take care of the
household
one at a time
and the other girl's not pregnant with
your baby right
hell no she's she's for sure she's not
even pregnant she's not pregnant